to Turkey now we're president Reggie of
Tyria Pierre DeVaughn says a new safe
zone in northeastern Syria will create
an area where his government can
repatriate Syrian refugees he also wants
to keep this safe that the safe zone in
place to prevent Kurdish militants from
approaching the southern border now he
said he was determined to establish the
zone by now the end of September
but his government and the United States
have different ideas about how big the
zone should be heroin says he'll act
alone if there's no agreement meanwhile
Syrian refugees in Turkey say some are
already being deported to areas
including the north of Syria which they
say are far from safe DW met one woman
whose son was sent back against his will
Mohammad has been gone for almost two
months when all furusho thinks about
what happened to her son she feels
helpless lost in early August Mohamed
was riding a friend's motorbike in
Istanbul the bike wasn't registered
Mohamed was stopped by police and then
sent to a detention center about 12 days
later I got a call from Mohamed he said
they've taken me to Syria to eat Lib
that was his last phone call I haven't
heard from him since heartbroken when
they fled from Syria he was still a
small child now they have sent him back
to that place and I don't know where he
is
Istanbul asfar Tisch district is an area
where many Syrians live many here have
heard that the Turkish authorities have
been deporting refugees in recent months
and most of them are afraid that they
could be next when they started sending
people back I was so scared I didn't
leave my house there are more
restrictions on us now and people are
being deported back to Syria we can't
escape Turkey for Europe anymore because
it's too dangerous
I mean to do a lot sorry we Syrians used
to feel welcome here we feel like
unwanted migrants again Toma Doreen
Turkey has taken in more refugees from
Syria than any other country more than
3.6 million people in the space of a few
years hundreds of thousands live here in
Istanbul they've set up stores and
restaurants they've tried to build new
lives and while Turkish society
initially responded with remarkable
resilience hospitality is now rapidly
wearing thin chuck grassley bother us if
more of them come I don't want to live
in this neighborhood and in this country
anymore you don't get to maybe let
chalky said him I get along very well
with most of the Syrians here there are
some bad people but you get that
everywhere we want them to leave as soon
as possible we don't want them here
anymore
turkish President Recep Tayyip Erdogan
has recognized this change in public
sentiment in the past few weeks he has
made repeated promises that millions of
Syrians will return home to a so-called
safe zone that he wants to establish in
the northeast of Syria but the
government insists deportations are not
taking place
and that Syrians who are returning are
doing so voluntarily
murmur chatter ghost disagrees the
lawyers trying to help get over racial
son back from Syria Muhammad and his
family have valid Turkish documents and
protection status chuckle goose has
filed an appeal with turkeys
constitutional court so sending a person
to a war zone is a serious human rights
violation Mohammad is not an isolated
case this is happening to many Syrians
many have been deported in recent months
the lawyer says that many deported
Syrians attempt to return to Turkey
making a second escape from their
war-torn country illegally and often at
a high cost paying a lot of money to
smugglers and as dangerous as that might
sound Mohammed's mother otha is clinging
to any hope that she might see her son
again in safety